got your back
you got this gig before Hamilton they
did so first of all you were doing
rehearsals for Hamilton
not even this was seven months before
were seven months before Hamilton so
what was life like then uh life changed
pretty drastically on that day I
actually found out I was gonna be a
father that morning so that's the day
you found out that's the day my wife was
going off on a business trip and I was
still asleep she had to catch an early
flight and she said I think you might be
a dad all right I'll see you later and I
was like great what um and then you know
called her when I fully woke up to
confirm what she said and then I got the
call about Disney later that afternoon
and with that offer came a plane ticket
to New Zealand because the entire
creative team was attending a music
festival to do research and I'm flying
18 hours and I've got this secret I'm
gonna be a dad so it was really one of
those life-changing weeks don't mess
with Maui when he's on the breakaway and
the tapestry here in my skin is enough
of the pictures I win look where I've
been I think everything happened has
your kid seen Moana no but it'll be his
first film in the theatre yeah yeah I
don't think this is a movie you can wait
to till it gets to video I think the
ocean is so incredible and the effects
are so incredible I really want him to
see it on the big screen
course to find a brand new organ every
way we
you